what
is transfer learning
the idea of transfer learning is to
leverage the knowledge required by a
model train with lots of data
on another task the model a will be
trained specifically for task a
now let's say you want to train model b
for a different task
one option would be to train the model
from scratch
this could take lots of computation time
and data
instead we could initialize model b with
the same weights as model a
transferring the knowledge of model a on
task b
when training from scratch all the
model's weights are initialized randomly
in this example we are training a belt
model on the task of recognizing
if two sentences are similar or not
on the left it's trained from scratch
and on the right
it's fine tuning a pre-trained model as
we can see
using transfer learning on the
pre-trained model yields better results
and it doesn't matter if you train
longer the training from scratch is kept
around 70
accuracy or the retrain model beats the
86 percent easily
this is because pre-trained models are
usually trained on large amounts of data
but provides a model with a statistical
understanding of the language used
during pre-training
in computer vision transfer learning has
been applied successfully
for almost 10 years models are
frequently retrained on imagenet
a dataset containing 1.2 millions of
photo images
each image is classified by one of 1000
levels
training like this on labeled data is
called
supervised learning in natural language
processing
transfer learning is a bit more recent a
key difference with imagenet
is that the training is usually
self-supervised which means it doesn't
require us imagination for the labels
a very common pre-training objective is
to guess the next word in a sentence
which only requires lots and lots of
text gpd2 for instance
was retrained this way using the content
of 45 million links posted by users
on reddit another example of
self-supervised per training objective
is to predict the value of randomly
masked words which is similar to feeling
less pronounced tests you may have done
in school
but was retrained this way using the
english wikipedia
and 11 000 in published books
in practice transfer learning is applied
on a given model
by throwing away its head that is its
last layers focused on the
training objective and replacing it with
a new
randomly initialized ad suitable for the
task attempt
for instance when we invited you in the
birth model earlier
removes the advert classified mask words
and replaced it with a classifier with
two outputs
since our tasks add two levels to be as
efficient as possible
the pre-trained model used should be as
similar as possible to the task it's
fine tuned on
for instance if the problem is to
classify german sentences
it's best to use the german pre-trained
model
but with the good comes the bad the
pre-trained model does not only transfer
its knowledge
but also any bias it may contain
imagenet mostly contains images coming
from the united states and western
europe
the models fine tuned with it usually
will perform better on images from these
countries
open ai also studied the bias in the
prediction of its gpt3 model
which was between using the guest and
x-word objectives
changing the gender of the prompt from
e-wisebury to
she was very changed the predictions for
mostly neutral objectives
to almost only physical ones in the
model card of the gbt2 model
openai also acknowledges its bias and
discourages its use
in systems that interact with humans